um
[Laughter]
um
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pacman
he is a baby
[Music]
david pacman he is
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality
hold on but whoa whoa jesse will we we
gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman obeying
a male dog
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david patman
he is a baby
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pacman he is a beta male 1
[Music]
david pacman he is a baby
david you're not here to communicate i
really appreciate you coming on i'm
going to let you go it's a waste of time
to talk to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking bizarre
questions you're acting like an
idiot and you're wasting my time i
appreciate that
all right goodbye goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
of the sexual experience would ask the
young lady who's your daddy
this should be remixed if officer akimov
is watching
this could be the next remix masterpiece
dude because just wait till you see what
happens here oh officer officer akimov
is here
uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
no i'm a christian
[Music]
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
[Music]
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth
to reverence the word of god to trust it
to preach it
to teach it loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and
tons and tons of what happened
in prison that brought you to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
[Music]
george bush and george bush jr have been
penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
strong i didn't do it that's not my
problem
oh i got down on my knees
[Music]
and tons and tons of
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
loads and loads of money and
tons and tons of lives loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
let me say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done
except they've done it we've seen them
that certainly
seems to be a story that has been missed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and tons and tons of lives loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of live
loads and loads of money
and tons and tons of live
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow wow i almost need to just not even
stream
because of that that there's no way to
top that that's the new
single not from officer akimov but it's
office akimov
with a special shout out the background
vocals there
from i hope i'm pronouncing this
correctly marika
uh i hope i hope i'm saying that
correctly who's a fan of the show
and graciously contributed the
background vocals there that is really
something else
that's the same by the way office
akimov who did the a
dump song i'll just do a few seconds
just to remind you we're not going fully
into it i'm here and we're going to talk
about the indictment
but really strong and this is the same
office akimov who put this one together
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points
if you can sample trump saying massive
dumps and me talking about it in a song
please do it
[Music]
big massive dumps big massive dumps
[Music]
okay anyway so people remember that i
think that this is potentially grammy
material
um we saw uh that last week or the week
before
usher was at the white house we should
try
to get word of these two new tracks to
usher i think it's the type of stuff he
may be really really
interested in so that's what's going on
there
what is happening today many different
things are happening number one
we are standing by for a covid 19
update close friends for small backyard
cookouts
but with them and in fact to say we're
standing by may be wrong and
it's just it's going on i don't know if
something big happens here we will cut
to it
maybe dr anthony fauci will speak and
and we'll get to some of that stuff
but the big news the really big news
and we are standing by here the trump
organization and its cfo have been
indicted this is the first
indictment and here's my main takeaway
if you believe that alan weisselberg
the cfo of the trump organization was
acting completely by himself in this
alleged criminality
and donald trump didn't know about it
and don jr didn't know about it
and eric trump didn't know about it and
ivanka didn't know about it
you are living in a fantasy world that
is not how these businesses work
uh weisselberg is not going to say hey
let me keep secret but start doing all
of this different stuff
it's just not how it works so this we
don't know what is to come this may be
just the beginning
but what we do know is it's a fraud
exactly there is so much fraud going on
here
and maybe we'll even start with with
some of these articles
telling us what what it is that is going
on um
trump organization responds to
indictment
says it's an attempt to harm a former
president
the trump organization dismissed an
indictment against one of its longtime
employees
as a political maneuver designed to hurt
former president donald trump
predictable we knew that was exactly
what they were going to say
alan weiselberg the company's chief
financial officer
surrendered to the manhattan district
attorney's office on wednesday morning
is expected to be arraigned later in the
day that's what we are standing by for
right now
and supposedly it was going to happen
right around 2 p.m eastern oh let's
listen see if they have an update here
donald trump's business dealings
the first criminal charges against his
company have been filed
and are now just hours away from being
revealed in court
sources briefed on the investigation
tell abc news that charges against the
trump organization
and its longtime chief financial officer
alan weiselberg
include tax fraud weisselberger has
worked for the company since the 1970s
in one of his old books trump said of
weisselberg quote
he did whatever was necessary to protect
the bottom line
right replacing george this week is my
chief financial officer
alan weissel look at this guy and you
think george is tough
when you see allen sources briefed on
the investigation say the company and
weisselberg
are accused of avoiding taxes on french
benefits
including cars school tuition and
rent-free apartments
the charges come after the manhattan
district attorney obtained trump's tax
returns
and other financial records in a battle
that went all the way to the supreme
court
trump has long insisted he runs a clean
company totally the investigation
is politically motivated the
continuation of the greatest and most
disgusting witch
[Laughter]
weisselberg is the most important person
in the trump organization who is not a
member of the trump
family the big question now is whether
prosecutors can get him to testify
against donald trump right deidra chief
washington correspondent jonathan carl
thank you and a statement released to
abc news on behalf of the cfo
alan weisselberg after he surrendered to
authorities this morning in new york
saying weisselberg intends to plead not
guilty
and he plans to fight these charges in
court we will have full coverage of the
charges as they are expected to be
unsealed later this afternoon
right right here on abc news live so
that's what we're standing by for
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
we're hoping that that supposedly it was
going to be in the 2pm
eastern time hour which is just 19
minutes from now so we're monitoring
multiple
uh outlets as far as this goes if
anybody
sees any news that i'm missing about it
please let me know because i will want
to get that feed and get that going
um this this is why we are here but
let's get back
to the response in a statement the trump
organization
said weisselberg was being used as a
pawn in manhattan district attorney
cyrus vance's attempts to harm
trump the district attorney is bringing
a criminal prosecution
involving employee benefits that neither
the irs nor any other district attorney
would ever think of bringing the
statement said
this is not justice this is politics
we know vance has been investigating for
a long time
um michael cohen has been saying a lot
about it
uh michael cohen said this is just the
beginning
and uh i think i had one other article
here
trump organization cfo alan weisselberg
surrenders ahead of expected charges
alan weiselberg the cfo of trump org
surrendered to authorities early today
to face expected tax related charges
the first stemming from the manhattan
district attorney's
year lungs probe into former president
trump's
namesake company a grand jury handed
down an indictment against the company
itself
wednesday evening sources told cbs news
weisselberg has come under increasing
scrutiny by the manhattan district
attorney's office and the
new york ag in recent month given his
knowledge
mary mulligan who is weisselberg's
attorney says he will plead not guilty
the charges whoa easy there
easy there the charges remain under seal
expected to
relate to alleged failure to pay taxes
on corporate perks for trump
organization employees
it's a fraud like company cars and
apartments
fraud mr trump himself was not expected
to be charged
his attorney told fox news earlier this
week that's probably true
fraud but uh we we can only wait and see
uh at this point in time and expecting
maybe even within 15 minutes we will see
this afternoon these charges are going
to be unsealed
and again there is no it does not pass
the sniff test
that weisselberg would have been
involved in the fraud
and trump wouldn't know and don jr
wouldn't know
and ivanka wouldn't know and eric trump
wouldn't know there's just
no way that that is possible whatsoever
period full stop end of story okay
let me get to a few other things here
first of all
we are celebrating the first indictments
against the trump organization
and associates with a very special
coupon code
indictment 21. now many of you suggested
this coupon code previously
it wasn't the right time i have been
holding back the coupon code
it is now live indictment 21 and i do
want to say thank you to jeremy zimdars
for signing up on my website as well as
daniel keats
new members 1 and 2 today also before
this gets gets away from me i want to
say thanks to some twitch subscribers
darth bane
chief boris fiora's dracula father
the winter crow sven hout duck
company another one from fiora's dracula
father
um dr strong
kill tv alexander the grape
ms unlikely gamer duck company weather
boxer
um odw okay that's 11.
wow just a lot happening here uh
pretty pretty significant uh dumps
happening here dumps
uh we putting us at 13
right off the bat okay as we stand by
here for the announcement and the
reading of the charges
let me get to a few super chats ben
stroud says wow he wouldn't fold on
trump he took the charges for trump
wow why is everyone scared of trump he
is no one special just a common thug
con man ryan says scotus just backed
arizona voting restrictions is it
reasonable to assume
proper representation can only happen
after scotus reform and
is that likely i'd have to think about
that
i'm not sure about that horror fan says
that was as good as classic
stern great skit david sur pictures of
biden with desantis must go up
trump's patootie a mile we'll get to
that
david i beg of you to do a reaction to
the youtube video by dave rubin clips
called dave rubin top
moments of the second quarter 2021
let's take a look at that let's see if
we can find that
it sounds potentially uh memetic not
mimetic remember everybody
whoa hold on a second here let's take a
look at it
oh we're muted though how many people we
got in cali it was supposed to be like
is it like 70 million people how many
people we got in california yeah not not
exactly
by the way qatar can we confirm this i
believe it's the number two
oil exporter on earth but he decided to
sell it and make
500 million dollars by selling it to the
number two oil exporter qatar
okay she used to struggle with imposter
syndrome
that seems like a problem to me if
you're going to be in the cia
double agents triple agents quadruple
agents and now you've added in someone
with him
is this also now a comedy show you know
i don't know because
i learned last week that and on the joe
rogan show
that um steven crowder does a comedy
show we've reached out to you through
every proper channel i've tweeted a
couple times
we have repeatedly repeatedly on this
show reached out
through all the proper channels to her
team we haven't heard back i've
tweeted at her many times my tweets get
way more traffic than any of her tweets
do
um but otherwise at this point after
weeks
we also donated 50 bucks i've got the
stupid mug
you know it's just a pr campaign that's
all i think it is and i would say this
you know i said last week
that i think the caitlyn jenner thing is
just complete yes they still have not
responded to us why don't we follow up
again actually
uh and it's like you don't have to do
the show but if you can't even respond
then you're just not serious one way or
another
it says what are your thoughts on
caitlyn jenner for governor you know
look we tried to reach out they haven't
got back to us
by the way china also you know owns a
ton of our debt right we're we're in
massive massive debt to china and at
some point when they call in the tab
when they're like no no no no guys
all right yeah i'm kind of i'm kind of
bored by it i mean it's like it's all
nonsense i understand that but
all right good anyway we looked at a few
seconds of it denver says stop the drain
steal the swamp yeah exactly right
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times elements of bathrooms
looking at that very strongly we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
exactly uh okay also thanks
david what does the indictment mean the
indictment means that the trump
organization as well as its cfo have
been indicted this is just the first
step and potentially much more coming
we're going to find out more about that
a little bit hopefully soon in the 2pm
hour
eastern presumably what are the odds we
get a 10 000
electric vehicle credit in a future
reconciliation bill
i don't know is that even on the table i
didn't know anything about that
david sir coming in strongly with the
drops big
energy and god bless the united states
could indictments enrage the trump base
and hurt democrats
right maybe yeah i mean you know
anything's possible but
i wouldn't be too worried about it david
sir please my birthday was last week but
i was doing
the bridesmaids thing sure i don't know
and miss the streams can you say
destiny's name yeah of course
the other day actually i talked to
stephen kenneth destiny bonnell ii
and um it was a fine
conversation i do want to say thank you
to
jose fortuna who just signed up with the
coupon code
indictment 10 21 we are celebrating
these first indictments
against the trump org with the coupon
code
indictment 21 brian king using the
coupon code indictment 21
also thanks to teresa eamons all of whom
just signed up on my website
it is we've been waiting to deploy this
code for years my friends
today is the day and that code is
indictment 21.
do i have unban requests no unban
requests today
i am considering in a little bit going
through my voicemail with you guys
because we've been on vacation
i have 156 voicemails i have not
screened any of them i could actually
show you people say david you're
you're selecting stuff that's
particularly bad the voicemail
is just bad so i might do that
but i do have a a couple of other clips
i wanted to go through
with you guys um oh this is good
this is um a man from seekonk
is facing federal charges for his
alleged involvement in the january 6th
trump riots
and a very strange interview took place
now why isn't he wearing a shirt i am
not
i am not nor do i really know anyone who
just hangs out with no shirt
at home now i know there's a heat wave
maybe there's no ac and maybe that it's
as simple as that
but one of the strange things about the
program cops
is very often when police arrive at
people's houses they're not wearing a
shirt and they don't think to even put
one on
um so this guy's not wearing a shirt
might just be because it's hot
and here's here's the conversation i'm a
documentarian
and uh you know when as like you guys
when you guys hear of something you guys
show up as you do now and ask questions
or record and see what happens
so that's that's what i was doing there
so there are photos of you
reportedly kind of stomping on camera
equipment and stuff is that you
in that picture the fbi is putting out
um i would not like to comment
on that at this time you know my
instinct is if it's not you like if
someone showed me a picture from
istanbul last week and said this guy
looks a lot like you
and he's sexually harassing women on the
street is that you
i'm not going to say i don't want to
comment on that right now
i would say it's not me that's not me um
so it's it's an unusual answer for sure
but
i'm working everything out with the
courts and whatnot and
it's all being worked out so that's
really really strange stuff
that's that here is trump
at the border with greg abbott
and he's still talking about his
cognitive test
check this out but he did a test did i
ace it
i aced it and i'd like to see biden he
said he won't ace it he'll get the first
two there's 35 questions and
i think he's still wrong about the
number of questions even
uh let me just just to be thorough
um i montreal cognitive assessment let
me see here
are there 35 there's uh
it's no it's out of 30. so trump is
still
wrong even as to the number of questions
two or three are pretty easy they're the
animals
is this a lion a giraffe when he gets to
around 20 he's gonna have a little hard
time i think he's gonna have a hard time
with the first few actually
but uh so yeah he and then we fell in
love
he wants that taken and then later with
hannity
he was still doing this stuff stand back
and stand by
i'm in trouble with him we aced it i
think i can say that i aced it
did he get one he didn't get one
question wrong did he
30 out of 30. wow so now hannity rightly
says it's 30 questions
[Applause]
the crowd is cheering that the president
passed a dementia screening
like it it's that's what the crowd is
cheering about understand they're saying
yeah he passed the dementia screening a
little more difficult
after you get by 15 i would say but i i
heard the first three questions are is
it a giraffe
or an elephant right well you know
that's what the fact is they take the
first two or three questions and they
put that
and they put them in but let me tell you
they would not get those last 15 right
certainly not the last ten that i
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers um
okay so here's the actual test
um uh visuospatial executive begin
one a two oh i see okay so i'm guessing
it's one a
two b three c four 4d 5e
you have to copy the cube draw a clock
showing that it's 10 past
11. okay name a lion
this is a giraffe and this is a dog
right did i just get all three
points there it is
memory read a list of words like you
know
man woman camera tv no face velvet
church daisy red
so you do it once so somebody would say
sir please remember face velvet church
daisy red
and you would say face velvet church
daisy red and then they would wait five
minutes and they
would say sir please give us those
questions and you would say
face velvet church daisy red attention
read a list of digits
one digit per second subject has to
repeat them in the forward order
two one eight five
four and then you would say two one
eight five four and then they would say
sir or ma'am
repeat in reverse order seven four
two and you would say two four seven
okay read a list of letters the subject
must tap with his hands
each time you say a oh i see so hold on
i could do that with my mallet oh i
don't know where it is
so they would say f b a
c m n a
a you know etcetera serial seven
subtract subtraction starting at one
hundred okay i'm gonna do this with my
eyes closed so you've got
one hundred 93
86 79
72 65 58
51 44 it's okay so you go backwards in
that order
oh i guess you only need to do five of
them
language repeat i only know that john is
the one to help today
the cat always hid under the couch when
dogs were in the room okay
name the maximum number and words in one
minute that start with the letter
f you've gotta love get eleven okay fat
funny
french uh finagle okay you guys get it
um similarities between a banana and an
orange trump wants to know both the
oranges and the bananas of the
investigation that's what comes to mind
to me
um similarities between train bicycle
and watch ruler a train bicycle i assume
it means
things that republicans hate because
it's not a car burning gas
watch and ruler would be two items trump
doesn't use
those seem to be the similarities to me
okay so anyway so then they're asked
again about face velvet church daisy red
orientation if they can tell you the day
month year
place and city you get six points all
right so
i guess these are the tough ones trump
is talking about towards the end
i don't know so
that's what's going on there okay
um trump's still talking about that uh
cognitive test let me say a huge
thank you to kimberly alt who just
signed up with the coupon code
indictment 21. folks if you are just
joining us
the trump organization has indeed
been indicted along with its cfo alan
weisselberg
we might be minutes from the full
charges being announced
there's an arraignment happening
supposedly in the 2pm eastern hour
that's now
it and so if you're just joining us we
are celebrating this with the coupon
code
indictment 21. it will discount your
membership
an ungodly amount an ungodly amount at
joinpackman.com i don't even want to
tell you how much i don't want to get
indicted but that's what we are standing
by for
at this point in time any second
expected in court
and it will be an arraignment okay so we
are standing by
let's look at a few other super chats
that are coming in
um where is this
oh boy i can't even find them
okay no i got it is trump a comedian
search this video and prepare to laugh
tim poole capital edition remix i'm not
going to do that right now
your indictment coupon code is almost
indictable yeah i know that's why i'm
not even mentioning how big of a
discount it is
what is the trump organization that's
trump's business does it truly matter
when the republicans will vote for any
elephant
elephant branded crook and the jackass
democrats are
too incompetent to fight back yeah this
could encumber trump for a long time
this really could so i think this this
actually does make a difference
anytime i see news trump is in trouble i
think back to any other scandal he got
away with and immediately dismiss it
what gives this time we just have to
wait and see
we just have to wait and see david tell
the viewers that likes don't cause
national
national natural catastrophes absolutely
fear not if you like the stream it will
be you will be fine there will be no
hurricane or anything
today in canada we're remembering the
uncovering indigenous children buried
and celebrating cancel
amada day very powerful i don't know
anything about that
but i appreciate you telling me thoughts
on c-span ranking trump
fourth worst president behind franklin
pierce andrew johnson and james buchanan
it seems in the ballpark it seems in the
ballpark
people asking if today's criminal
charges go to court
yes we are standing by right now for the
arraignment
we are standing by as we speak for the
arraignment
got married on saturday surprisingly and
thankfully little talk of politics
but found two of my husband's relatives
that are big fans of yours love it
i appreciate that is the last question
on the test how many questions are on
this test i i don't i didn't see that
chris says what are your thoughts on the
speed of democrat judge approvals
it must it should be faster it should be
faster
for sure hi david love the sound board
would you consider letting viewers
suggest new sound
bites absolutely i have a couple of new
things that people
i have some ben shapiro stuff i don't
know if this will really be relevant but
i have them
i'm a sexist for saying that women are
more than just you know their wet ass p
words
okay yeah you effin with some wet ass p
word
bring a bucket and a mop for this wet
ass p word
i said certified freak seven days a week
so that i've the
somebody sent me these there's some
horrors in this house hold up
yep this sounds like there there's some
there's something that is going on here
that is not biologically normal
i would say so yeah p word p word is
female genitalia
p word p word is female genitalia that's
a good one and then lastly
wet ass p word make that pull out game
weak
there you go so that's basically it
yeah you effin with some wet ass p word
bring a bucket and a mop
for this wet ass p ward so that's what i
have
and then i have a couple biden things
come on man
and will you and then just a couple
miscellaneous
yeah good okay and then some crowder
oh no sam cedar that's
the best sam who right so
that's basically what i have and then
just endless endless trump stuff
um you know you've got i won't play all
of them but big massive dumps
dumps they call them dumps and then
we've got a lot of sir stuff
congratulations sir you just won the
election mr president sir
mr president sir how are you sir you're
on the cover of time magazine again
sir i think you're doing very well sir
i don't know yeah so anyway we got a ton
of this stuff
people can send them in absolutely
absolutely no question about it
and then um i still have also
kind of like these quick uh quick
shortcuts like if we say
oh sir how many people are currently
subscribed to the new youtube channel i
can just pull it up and we have an
instant live count
71.90 we got that six and seven thousand
uh whoa
there we go a little bit of a drop in um
if we say oh
what have i been uh what did i what did
i put on instagram lately we can pull
that up with one click
so a lot of these things are just to
make things easier for me
um yeah i don't know how many people saw
by the way oh god
i just got blocked from my own instagram
all right well forget that we will close
that out for now
but um so yeah this it's all working
really well
it's all working really well i think is
the message okay
we just received a huge
dump of new memberships here i want to
say thank you to jamie clark
signing up with the coupon code
indictment 21
participating in the celebration of the
indictments today
ruth costly signing up with the code
indictment 21
billy stockbridge has signed up as well
as
raul van heerden
that's four big thank you to
bri brianne mape using the coupon code
and louis labrie coupon code is
indictment 21
also kim lewis and sigar siobhan
signing up with the coupon code
indictment 21 putting us at 25.
also in all seriousness thanks to people
supporting on twitch d
granites frankie kurt km klezlew
symbolic gamer light chaser ben lewitt
sumi long cheerios and oj
as well as darth bane and chief boris
all signing up to support with those
twitch subs
we may be moments away moments away
from the arraignment of the trump
organization and trump cfo
alan weiselberg let's listen and see
what's happening he would be indicted in
the meantime i'm going to see if i can
get a cnn feed going as well for when
this happens
refused to cooperate now is the time for
the district attorney to more or less
call his bluff
and say fine you're not going to
cooperate we're going to indict you
but i do think i do have the sense that
this is
a first step on what's going to be a
much
longer campaign in the months to come
let's see if we can get a live cnn feed
as well
it better be the let's pull on a thread
and see what we can get or else
okay oh wow we're standing by at trump
tower wow stand by
i will for the next couple of hours as
we await word here thank you so actually
let me get signed in here just so we
don't then lose the feed
um let's see what was what is my uh
i don't even know my username here
see if i can get something all back up
ahead i will have a live one-on-one
interview
with donald trump's former personal
attorney michael cohen
on what he thinks this means for the
former president and
okay good so we we are standing this it
seems like there it could be any moment
now
um that this uh that this could happen
and we will see the
the full charges read out and i i
imagine it's going to be
explosive okay let me do a few more
super chats while we wait and then we're
going to get to some voicemails we have
like a
it's just packed with voicemails because
of the vacation
correction canada day autocorrect fault
um david you
should search laser eye sam cedar versus
crowder on youtube yeah i don't want to
just be searching
random videos for the whole stream but
my 86 year old mom just did a memory
test in the uk
she identified 10 animals and objects
and their relationships
she did fail to say a kangaroo was a
marsupial that should be required genus
family it should all be required yeah
david being mixed and asian-american i
am fundamentally opposed to identity
politics but not reductively
well said that's pym hi david love you
my brother
thank you david in the last few weeks
over 900 unmarked graves of first
nations children have been uncovered
at sites of former residential schools
in canada wow
that is horrifying espress drops in a
brutal hundred dollar super chat and
says is my super chat
tax deductible it is not it is not
always uh check with your accountant
that is not certainly
uh financial advice raul says signed up
cheers from the netherlands thanks for
all appreciate that
johnny minogue says david thought you
were on vacation glad to see you hope
you're not missing out on rnr no i've
been gone the last six days
and i'm back and i'm heading out again
tonight for the long weekend and the
next
the next podcast actually won't beetle
tuesday uh but i'm just streaming this
seemed this seemed worthy
kind of just had an off day in between
trips so i'm back
phil says how do you debunk the democrat
versus republican state cities argument
by the right ah
perfect i will tell you exactly how to
debunk it
let's pull it up because i've done it
let's see if i can find it david pakman
democrat cities crime
maybe yep here it is hey dave
okay here we go i'm gonna run this on
1.5 x speed
here is how i would debunk it most
dangerous cities run by democrats
so this is a pretty old trope uh and i
maybe we can kind of address this piece
by piece
donald trump and republicans have been
harping on this a lot uh democrat run
cities are riddled with violence
so vote for me instead of jobiden even
though of course trump is already
president and there's still violence in
those cities so here's what there's a
few things you have to understand
most cities are run by democrats period
so violent cities are run by democrats
and non-violent cities are run by
democrats they use crass terminology
additionally
the violence is disproportionately in
urban areas so
when you think about cities instead of
areas you start to get this talking
point that trump has been repeated so if
you look at
mayors 35 of the 50 largest cities are
run by democrats
13 are run by republicans and two are
democratic-leaning independents
so because more cities are run by
democrats you have to account for that
in your analysis
the large republican cities are san
antonio i'm sorry san diego
run by republican mayor san diego
jacksonville jacksonville is more
dangerous than the average in florida
it's run by a republican
fort worth texas run by republican is
more dangerous than the average of texas
in terms of crime rates
el paso texas is safer than average for
texas oklahoma city run by republican
more dangerous than average so what you
really just have to understand is that
there is a sort of base rate bias that
you have to account for the largest
cities
run by democrats are the largest cities
in the country uh crime tends to uh
be greater in places with large
population density for a number of
different reasons that we understand
cities have more crime because they're
more densely populated cities also vote
more for democrats
because there are more cosmopolitan
higher education rates we know more
educated people tend to vote for
democrats instead of republicans
and that does not directly link to the
crime is because the mayor is a democrat
and this has been widely debunked and it
doesn't even pass the sniff test there
is not actually any correlation
between crime and democrat democratic
mayors when you account account for
crime being more prevalent in cities and
the fact that democrats
leak so that's the gist of it okay let's
just do a little bit of it even at a
faster 2x
speed just for just for kicks a majority
of the cities in the united states
including cities below crime rates now
when you look at the south for example
and the south at both the city and state
level is disproportionately under
republican rule
they have some of the highest poverty
rates in the united states does that
mean that republican rule causes poverty
maybe it does and that's a better
argument quite frankly than crime and
so-called democrat cities but you still
have to look at details and understand
more to really know what it is that is
going on now when this conversation
comes up we also shouldn't ignore a
broader context about crime
the crime has been decreasing for
decades overall and we might be better
served understand
okay anyway so you guys get the picture
that was that one was my special request
because people were people were asking
for that
uh okay we are standing by for what
might be
oh any moment any moment we we may see
uh these this arraignment
of the trump organization criminally we
are
celebrating this fact with the new
coupon code
indictment 21 indictment 21
saves you an insane amount on my website
and it's
it's a great day mike says who should we
believe when it comes to the conflicting
guidance on masks between the cdc and
the who
who would you consider more credible i
am not ready to wade into that right now
i don't have anything definitive to say
and so i
don't see the advantage of wading into
it at this point in time
jason asked do you think the indictment
will result in banks calling loans in
early i saw people speculating
that would corrupt the company um
i haven't read anything about that at
this point
other super chats uh pym tool
says den pekiro esprez dumps in a second
hundred dollar super chat says
the tax deduction was a trump
organization joke i understand
i understand thank you i really
appreciate that
hi from the uk love your channel get
most of my us news from you and tyt
have you signed the petition to prevent
bezos from returning to earth yet i have
not i i don't know much about it
okay so we're caught up there as far as
that goes
okay let me go i'm gonna do an exercise
oh that was weird
hold on a second oh still on break i'm
going to do an exercise now with you
guys people say david when you play
voicemails you're like cherry picking
either really boring ones or crazy ones
play the good ones
let's go through them one by one we've
been off for six days
so now i have fresh voicemails okay
let's just go through them one by one
you'll see what it's like
to actually go through these hi david
uh my name is shashi i was rewatching
um or catching up brother on your show
from yesterday and i got to the michael
savage
segment of the show and first of all it
gave me embarrassment that i used to
listen to that guy i take him seriously
but secondly
his analogy of comparing the critical
race theory stuff to the holocaust from
my busy
uh all right so that goes on for two
minutes that's not a good fit
for the show here's another one no we're
going one at a time
hi david bizarro conspiracy theory
coming your way i just made this up
watching your
video on diamond and silk so are
diamonds still
slaves like were they like are they like
descendants of like actual slaves that
were like owned
by some of these republicans all right
here's the next one
hey david it's ryan i gotta i gotta see
if you've
seen this clip there's an oan clip where
the guy is so radical that he actually
calls for the execution
of anyone that he says stole the
election from donald trump and he says i
don't know if it's
thousands of people hundreds of people
thousands of people or maybe more
and and he just calls for their
execution literally
on oan calling for mass execution okay
um here's the next one hey um
i remember a couple years ago alex jones
once um invited emma vigeland on
his show to debate him and she
turned it and she uh refused
uh i'm just wondering what's up with
that okay so see like
there would there's no st i don't know
some people just don't know how a show
works but
a seg i can't do a segment on emma
vigeland turning down an invitation
three years ago you know i it's just
it's not a segment for the show
um okay
let's see uh next one
hi david i signed up for a membership on
your site and i used a
coupon code and now i'm in prison please
post bail for me
all right that's that's sort of funny uh
here's the next one
hello david this is joshua from texas on
your june 24th show
taking back the flag was brought up
while i agree that we should be looking
at patriotism through a lens of the good
our country has accomplished
how much it has improved as that's the
more logical approach
i would like to point out that we're not
going against logical and sometimes
doing theological can be the quickest
way to feel anyway it's like you know i
i know in the first 10 seconds that
that's not uh that's not usable
hi david um i'm with uh light
my name's uh andre i'm with lights light
script
uh productions uh and
word oh hold on this guy sends a uh yeah
okay hold on
that guy actually gives personal info so
i'm gonna skip that um all right
hey david i was wondering if you uh had
any thoughts about that
bogus uh audit that's going on in
arizona i don't think enough attention
yeah he's like you know i've done 10
segments about the arizona audit
um here's we're going one by one i'm not
skipping anything okay hey you know
david i find this uh
after this general millie's comment
really fascinating because what he's
doing is he's addressing one of the most
fundamental tenets
of the of what of trumpism
and that and and and this new
conservatism
and that is this that smart people are
stupid
and uh you know and what he's saying is
that he finds this offensive
and that you know he thinks that
you know people should be smart okay
um oh here's ronald reagan ronald reagan
called in
d-man this is reagan um i wanted to
address something with you
that's been bothering me for some time
um
i'll start with a story about
my personal life i okay and again it's
three minutes long
total love to raygun but we just we
can't you know we don't do three minute
voicemails on the show this is why it's
so
tough to find voicemails for the show
um it's like one out of maybe
a hundred that that are sort of usable i
want to say a huge thank you to bruce
bruce clithero who is new member number
32 today and used the coupon code
indictment 21 we are moments oh look
here is alan weisselberg
wearing a mask and being brought in
handcuffs to court
look at this trump cfo is perp walked
ladies and gentlemen
trump's cfo in handcuffs it's not trump
but he's in handcuffs
wow look at this the perp walk for
trump's
top a top guy
that is something else right there stand
back and stand by
there he is there is the first video of
alan weisselberg
masked safely masked and also
in cuffs being brought into court to
face
charges presumably for the things he did
uh for donald trump sir sir sir
ladies and gentlemen congratulations sir
you just won the election
that is exactly right some kind of
reverse lottery that alan weisselberg
seems to have won
or lost and uh we are the arraignment is
reportedly happening
right now we are outside the courthouse
and we could be just moments moments
moments moments
from uh hearing all about this sir your
wife is up in the air
yeah exactly um all right and and we i
mean people are just going crazy
i'm if you were driving okay please
pull over because i'm about to tell you
something crazy
because of these indictments today
uh the coupon code indictment 21 has
been created on my website people can't
believe it
i don't want anybody driving off the
road in a fit of ecstasy
but we are just moments here we have no
live
visual in the courthouse we saw a cuffed
allen weisselberg
just being dragged in to face justice
for his
alleged crimes committed uh on the
behalf of the trump organization
and that is that is basically it my
friends they are cuffed
and they are going into court
okay uh no but in all seriousness the
the arraignment is happening right now
any second those indictments will be
unsealed
a few other super chats here
i love your ben shapiro impression
deepak do you think the cosby case
getting tossed will throw ice on the
metoo movement
i don't know about that i'm going to
talk about that one when we're fully
back from vacation
will liberal dems veto bipartisan
infrastructure bill if no budget
reconciliation deal is accompanying it
seems dems are walking a fine line here
i i've been away six days i don't i
don't even know what's going on with
that if i'm perfectly frank
uh support indictment in principle but
too reductive
um okay it's another pym tool
of five head take apparently it looks
like something may be happening
let's let's listen kind of work up to
unraveling the whole thing
let's get our audio is today
well you know the strategy has always
always has to be that you bring a charge
that you can prove beyond a reasonable
doubt
okay so we're going to keep waiting in
right now
in the courthouse right now is donald
trump's longtime
cfo alan weisselberg
he was just dragged in in cuffs
and an n95 or kn
95 mask unbelievable stuff
in the meantime let's listen to just a
few other
voicemails that are coming in just to
give you guys an impression of what i
get
hey david my name is michael cohen from
sacramento and
i just wanted to express a thought that
was
spurred on by your discussion of
uh the plan in florida to start
teaching about the evils of communism in
their public schools
and uh get your opinion on this as well
um i think communism gets kind of a bad
rap
and i don't necessarily think it's an
ideal form of government or anything
like that
but what i do think is that
the a lot of the major examples we have
of
communist governments center around some
kind
again you know this goes on for three
three minutes we've talked about this ad
nauseam
there's nothing i can do with it
hi david my name is obi i'm from texas
and i have a question about politicians
telling the truth because it just seems
like
people that they are scouting lies
every single day yes politicians lie
you know there's nothing i would i would
be able to do with that
hey pacman was listening to your show
how you are so pumped uh unfortunately
uh
hate to tell you but uh president trump
is still the president
you better do some research my friend is
from argentina
and she told me that she's surprised for
being an argentine part
that you wouldn't know anything about
this right argentinians would know
all about election fraud in the us
naturally it's really sad that you think
that he's not the president and joe
biden is not even joe biden that's a
clone
right you better do some resource guy
okay i just want to help you out here
all right you've been so pumped is he
saying
pumped or punked no brainwashed my
friend told me
and she's sad too because she's
argentina it's funny also because like
why would another argentinian know
whether my views about american politics
are right or wrong
because i'm argentinian you need another
argentinian to comment about what i say
about american politics that's weird
let's see if we can get a couple more
here again we're going in order as you
can see they're essentially all not
usable
hi david i just wanted to comment on a
couple of bits from the 6 24
episode june 24th um i really like your
uh your dry humor your deadpan comedy
and you you hide these little gems in
your show
and when i catch them i just i just love
it so
it was i'm liking this boy this is good
this is good so far about the uh the guy
saying that the meeting is not over he
said
i think it was more of an empirical
question the meeting is clearly over
and you just went ran right through it
and kept going and i was dying i was
you're killing me sometimes um i i just
love it
this is a hero caller another thing i
wanted to mention was you had the caller
that mentioned
the democrats need to take back the flag
and i
i agree with that caller i agree with
that guy i've had that same idea
um in my lifetime and uh i think that
the democrats should not have
have uh surrendered the flag to the
republicans uh as clearly we've seen
in the last 12 months that uh you know
that we're obviously patriots and
supporters of the flag
all right that's actually not bad that's
not a bad uh that's not a bad voicemail
um look at another
hi um my name is chris and i'm from
tennessee and i just saw your
race um your like critical race theory
um
video and i was wondering because you do
purport yourself to be a critic
of um critical race there and you feel
or you said that you felt that um
it would worsen race solutions and
um you know and so with this one it's
like okay
i've got seven or eight segments on
critical race theory
so what this would be one more segment
where i would just kind of like
reiterate the same stuff so anyway
that's just like to give people a sense
of how tough it is to find
um to find voicemails to use on the show
if you're just joining us the trump
organization
as well as uh donald trump's
organizational ceo
alan weisselberg have been uh indicted
alan weisselberg has just been dragged
into court in
cuffs and a mask and any second they're
going to step out and we will have
the full announcement uh as to
what the charges are it's a fraud so
we're standing by for that
um i want to say thank you to people
that these are just such great people
um hillary calen just signed up for a
membership on my website with the coupon
code
indictment 21. we are celebrating the
first indictments
edwin tobias just signed up with the
coupon code
indictment 21 and mark castriotti
just signed up with the coupon code
indictment 21. this is a new coupon code
today only
uh you can sign up out on my website and
save a bunch of money
and i will say your name and the coupon
code also want to say thanks over on
twitch to
bedwell as well as jay tandaway
microbe luche d granitz
for a sub and a gift as well as
funky kurt oh wait no funky kurt i
already think okay so it's just the five
putting us at 40. beautiful the website
did go down yesterday for a moment it
had nothing to do with
with memberships it was we just had to
reboot the server
we had a couple new applications
installed that allow me to very closely
monitor every single one of you no i'm
kidding um
we had a couple new things installed on
the website we needed a restart
but it was all it was all fine other
super chats coming in
this is exciting can't wait for their
court trials i hope the trial is live
whoop whoop that's the sound of the
police
do you think trump will be popular in
jail i don't believe trump will do a day
in jail as i said before
when will the left admit the conspiracy
among eligible voters to remove trump as
evidenced by the vote count right
there was a conspiracy more than 80
million
americans together said let's go and
vote this guy out
and they went out there and they did it
that is the uh
that that is absolutely true
um let's see what else we've got here
um
oh man yeah the other uh
oh man like there's there i didn't even
know if i wanted to get into there's a
guy who keeps messaging me
with covid stuff saying that
coveted tests are basically don't exist
they're just manipulated
um and that the vaccine has motor oil
and um we wrote and just said future
emails will be blocked
and it seems to have very very much
triggered the guy
maybe that's something for next week i
can't even really deal with that right
now
it's just yeah it's too much it's too
much
yeah thank you to haha dead and short
brief
for the twitch subs i very much
appreciate that
do you think this negative press is good
for trump
no i don't but listen i'm going to make
this commentary next week
but i'm going to give you sort of like
the the short version of it right now
on oh wait a second is this the start of
this event no this doesn't seem like
it's
it uh we watched together trump's rally
last saturday
and he has another rally coming up this
saturday which which i may cover we'll
see
um my takeaway
from the rally and and just from the
general environment of the republican
party right now
is that if trump is healthy and runs in
2024
i see uh 82 year old joe biden
having a really tough time winning
and if it's kamala harris i also see her
having a really tough time
winning um i at this point
am very concerned that uh
either either um biden
saying i'm not running for re-election
and it being kamala
or an 82-year-old joe biden i think
both would not necessarily
inspire and activate that many
democratic voters and i am
very worried that the exact same sort of
being back on their haunches that took
place in 2016 will
will happen again now i know people are
saying trump's not healthy now he's
obese
i know you what i'm saying is if he's
healthy enough to run okay
now yes trump will almo will also be be
quite old at that time
i just am having a bad feeling about it
and i'm not even articulating it
um i'm not even articulating it super
clearly
yet i'm gonna sort of put my thoughts
together in time for the show next week
but if it's trump 24 versus
biden i think it will be a real uphill
battle for joe biden
and um if it's trump versus kamala
i just have serious questions about it
the midterms and how the midterms go
people are pointing out that's
also going to make a difference for sure
and how the midterms go i have
there's no doubt about that there's no
doubt about that but
if you you know what what i'm telling
you is if you say to me
how do i let's assume trump runs 24 how
am i feeling about it against biden
i'm not in the position of biden's got
this uh biden's got this in the in the
can
that's not my feeling he's got it in the
bag not at all
not at all that's not at all the feeling
i have
there's some people saying it's going to
be trump versus sanders i would bet
almost any amount of money
that the 2024 presidential election
does not come down to trump as the
republican nominee and bernie is the
democratic nominee i would take
almost any bet on that
all right let's see standing by here
let's see what's going on it's really
interesting hearing all these details
coming out of the courtroom the first
thing that really struck me alison is
the fact that weisselberg entered the
courtroom
with his hands cuffed if you remember at
the center of these allegations they're
tax crimes not a violence
safely cuffed but they actually took
those cuffs off as he sat down at the
defense table
and we're actually getting more
information about the allegations that's
what we talked about earlier we'd be
watching for
here prosecutors are alleging a 15-year
tax scheme these charges include 15
felony counts wow conspiracy
grand larceny and falsifying tax records
now they are alleging that weisselberg
avoided taxes on 1.7
million dollars in income there is no
way the trumps didn't know about this
no way in hell obligation that employees
at the trump organization
including mr weisselberg received perks
but again this wasn't free coffee this
wasn't just car service this was
allegedly free apartments
school tuition free cars those
are the kinds of benefits that could add
up to tens hundreds here
over a million dollars so that's going
to be the crux
of this case these are significant
allegations and it will be most
interesting to see
when mr weisselberg and his attorneys
sit down later today or tomorrow and
assess this evidence
if this is enough to change his mind on
cooperating with prosecutors
so tara one more time can you just spell
that out again
that what they spelled out in court was
more than just perks i mean they went
into
what sounds like i guess bigger things
unless it all falls under the umbrella
of perks
yeah just give us that litany again what
they went into is
oh sorry paul
sorry sorry paula can you hear me
now i can hear you yes alice so sorry um
can you just give me that litany again
of what they just spelled out in court
because
it sounded like it was bigger than just
perks where you were talking about grand
larceny
and you were talking about tax fraud can
you just spell out that laundry
but guys weisselberg acted alone trump
had no i
despite being an incessant micromanager
trump had no clue what
weisselberg was doing big event these
are significant charges
they're alleging a 15 year long
tax fraud scheme so they're alleging
that for 15
years the trump organization and or mr
weisselberg were trying to avoid
paying taxes specifically when it comes
to mr weisselberg they're alleging that
he tried to avoid paying taxes
on 1.7 million dollars in income
so they're alleging that he received
some of these extra benefits not as
direct paycheck but
received income in other ways and didn't
properly report it
for tax purposes so when it comes to not
paying on 1.7 million dollars of income
that is a significant charge and again
what will be interesting to see
is that this evidence now that it's been
revealed is enough to change his mind if
he will
now willing to be cooperate with
prosecutors against his former boss
wow okay well thank you very much let me
bring in wow
analysts again uh we we are joined again
by laura
ellie abby and jen rogers okay laura
so tell me what you just heard there 15
felony counts
when she did a 15 year scheme that in my
mind said for every year
that you fail to pay taxes it represents
a separate count
which means that you have i think it's a
minimum depending upon the amount
about seven years per count if i'm not
mistaken under new york law
and so you add that up you're talking
about a very significant
perspective sentence of course it's very
rare that someone would get the maximum
if convicts on all of those counts
we're not talking about small potatoes
here what's unsurprising
is that this indictment did not simply
rely
on statements about fringe benefits was
far more expansive
filing fraudulent documents other
aspects that paula laid out for us
but again it goes all right everybody if
you're just joining us the trump
organization
was reportedly indicted last night
trump's cfo alan weisselberg
is in court right now with masks and
cuffs
and reports from inside the courthouse
are that
trump's cfo long time cfo much
celebrated cfo trump saying this is the
guy
this is the best guy he's tough and he's
great has been charged with a
15 year sequence
of 15 felonies 15 years 15 felonies if
you're joining us
the audience is absolutely losing their
mind
we have uh people just dumping in
memberships using the coupon code
of indictment 21 people clearly thrilled
about this
i want to say thank you to heather
mclaughlin who just signed up on my
website with the code
indictment 21 alexa torres
just signed up with the code indictment
21.
farren franzak signing up with that very
special code
as well as christopher anderson the code
is a direct reference to
today's indictments they call them dumps
and i want to say uh thank you to
everybody who's been taking advantage of
that what a day what a day
any second allen weisselberg is going to
come out of court
um i'm guessing that the the cuffs come
off
when he makes bail is my sense
and um we i don't know who we will hear
from whether it will be his lawyers
prosecutors weisselberg i don't know
uh but 15 a number playing really
prominently today
and um it is unbelievable what is going
on
let's see
where i i want to see where i left off
here
i just drove off the highway in ecstasy
yeah i know this is the problem i was
being
careful about mentioning the coupon code
because i was worried people would drive
off the road
be really careful out there okay will
weisman flip it it's weisselberg yeah
it's not weissman will trump
organization take such a hit that it
affects trump's personal finances it's
too early to know
it's too early to know right now as cool
as the title of this live stream as i
hold hopes in check until i see the
words
trump criminally convicted i would not
hold my breath for that
necessarily okay do you think warren
would make a good opponent it's
too early to say will the trump or go
down with a domino effect sort of like
that trump foundation right i would love
to see that that would be
amazing david why have progressives
recently began
to delegitimize russiagate has your
opinion changed
uh i i haven't seen anything about that
i don't know
enjoy the extra bucks for failing at
super chat
all right thank you it's hard not to be
a dumer when a serial liar and fraudster
who encouraged an insurrection and is
now being investigated for crimes likely
will win if he runs against the
incumbent president that's a sad state
of affairs
yeah no doubt about it um
jason says is 15 years enough to bring
down the whole company
i don't know i don't know but you know
15 felony counts this is very serious
very serious and it definitely
endangers the trump organization which
you love to see
you love to see we're keeping our
fingers crossed i'm endlessly enter
skitoshi nakayobro says i'm endlessly
entertained
by the trump soundboard you have david
please never stop
being awesome and god bless the united
states
pym tool says this is delicious not to
gloat but
wow strong 15 felony counts is exciting
that's tickling my fancy crazy nate says
i sent you a voicemail about the mitch
fund by btc
okay marco says are you coming to berlin
in august
no uh so i uh i don't know that i was
ever going to berlin
i i was going to be in germany in august
because there's just a lot of
uncertainty right now i decided
i'm going to make it a single country
trip and that country is going to be
spain and spain alone i'm foregoing
there was going to be a sort of
frankfurt to france switzerland
ending in italy road trip and it's not
happening
um i just don't feel like dealing with
the logistics and
uh i'm going to be in spain not madrid
not madrid
i'm going to be in northern spain and
very much looking forward to it
but no i'm not going to be in uh
in berlin not scheduled to be in berlin
at any point in time right now
okay i may go into northern portugal the
city of puerto is a fantastic place
and uh yeah so we'll see we'll see how
that all goes
david do you think it's worth our time
to argue with republicans when they
spread misinformation in our presence or
is it a waste of energy
i i think the best thing to do is to ask
them use a socratic method of
questioning
to say where did you get that
information okay hold on it looks like
things are happening here
plead not guilty here is ellen oh these
are live pictures this is live
allen weisselberg is leaving the court
reverses from earlier
he is leaving now alex is leaving he has
been uncuffed
as you can see ellie he's not handcuffed
this time is he right so he's could have
been released as laura coates just said
we'll have to figure out what the terms
of that release are has he been released
on his own recognizance which just means
we trust you to come back has there been
some bail condition some limitation will
he be under house arrest
something like that but yeah these
proceedings are quick you're advised of
your rights you plead not guilty
and then you walk out he will go home
right now the question
he may be confined to his home sometimes
when someone's released like this
the judge will say you can't leave your
home or you can't leave the state or you
need special permission or you have a
curfew
so those details i think will get you
yeah guys why wouldn't you trust the guy
accused of 15 felonies perpetrated over
a 15-year period not to do anything
wrong while he's out on no bail
right i mean of course just let him out
action will continue certainly i mean
alan weisselberg is now
starting this litigation process so he
will have a status conference day you
know his
his case will proceed but he and his
lawyers will certainly be talking this
was clearly this last last-ditch effort
by prosecutors to bring him into the
fold to make him a cooperator
and that's the decision that's facing
them now
and do you think jen that something
changes now i mean what we had heard
was that alan weisselberg had not been
cooperating
with investigators and with prosecutors
but i know that things can change
after you're indicted in your experience
do things move faster now
you know it's really hard to say i think
in cases like this in white collar cases
the defendant and his lawyers are often
meeting and speaking with prosecutors
all along about what the charges are
going to be they will have told him in
advance what he's facing so it won't be
a surprise to him it's not like
he walked into court this morning and
learned that he was being charged with
much more than he anticipated
so if he changes his mind it's really
from the
the kind of thought process that ellie
and laura were talking about the kind of
cold hard reality
of being put in handcuffs of going to
the court all right so we're standing by
potentially for him exiting the
courtroom it's not clear which door this
will happen from and we're just we're
watching it all
i do want to continue oh whoa hold on
here we go here we go
facts but that can be an important
weisselberg in the middle with a sort of
roundish mask
i don't know we'll just have to see a
cadre of people
a phalanx women right now we assume with
his attorneys there
um he we also understand that the trump
organization lawyers are there um
looks like he's getting into a suburban
of some kind and
going to drive away we have some new
details that we're just getting in
though
about what happened in the courtroom so
prosecutors
said that weisselberg attempted to
conceal his participation
in the scheme with the knowledge of the
company quote
even now there's been no attempt to
impose discipline
on members of the company manhattan
prosecutor carrie dunn
said there is no clearer example of a
company that should be held
responsible prosecutors asked
wesselberg's
for wesselberg's passport to be taken
suggesting that he may be a flight risk
saying he has been and will remain cfo
of this international company there is
quote ample record of travel by private
jet
ample means to support himself out of
our jurisdiction ellie your take on that
so what are the things judges think
about when
letting someone out on bail like alan
white what a day what a day i mean
really unbelievable what is happening
here can you explain why you think trump
won't ever go to jail you know i've done
it so many times i just don't feel like
doing it again right now
um i think that it's not super likely
trump will be charged but if he is
charged
it's not super likely trump will be
found guilty of anything and if he is
found guilty
it's not likely that he'll be sentenced
to prison and if he were
sentenced to prison it would probably be
a suspended sentence so
i just i just don't see it i just don't
see it
this is great news but i can't get too
excited or else this plus my bluetooth
addiction will have me absolutely
decommissioned
okay careful there juicy bacon i'm
pitching in 15
for 15. keep your shine on david great
job thank you
congratulations trump org don't drop the
soap yeah i don't like that stuff yeah
that's not uh yeah i mean the the fact
that when you go to prison oh whoa hold
on a second here we go
taxes on 1.7 million dollars
of income is this what you expected
could we listen to this guy this is more
than i expected it goes on for a longer
period of time
i think the key thing to look for here
why don't we have audio
and we got a little bit of color about
it with some of the things that were
said in court
is the degree to which we should be
hearing what the eight with the
what what and to mask it
i think that's really key because it's
one thing to say hey
you messed up you should have put all of
this on your taxes you didn't
you owe all this money you owe penalties
etc
it's a different thing entirely to say
you purposefully intentionally knowingly
some combination of those things
went out of your way to mask this and
maybe they'll they'll roll that back
maybe they wouldn't have been able to
see all that yeah
anyway the reason i don't like prison
rape jokes is because
the fact that our prisons are so
dysfunctional that they can't even
protect
prisoners from being raped shouldn't be
something we celebrate as an additional
punishment i just
i just disagree with it and reject it
completely and i've talked about that
before
um okay let's see
people are saying msnbc is carrying this
stuff
more line
to strongly let's see if i can get this
the msnbc feed going
uh we're very concerned about that so
that in the future hold on a second
if some prosecutor in a different
political
jurisdiction
see what we've got now there's an ad
plane
i think this may work let's see
the ad blocker doesn't block this it's
crazy this
is our shop oh my god the clothing 19
vaccines are ready
[Music]
okay this is msnbc where i'm told that
they are actually running the uh
running the the statements that are
being made
we're gonna get to it momentarily
okay here we go in the civil context the
irs has
never made a case like this we cannot
find where the irs has ever made a case
like this
and we're all aware all of you and all
of us
are aware of the very significant
financial
crimes that have occurred by
large financial institutions where this
office did not take them on
did not prosecute them going back to
2008 the financial collapse of the
united states
many of the firms that were involved
both newsmax and ntd have microphones
there you guys see that
go after those firms and drag them into
court those companies into court
and we're talking about a trillion
dollars in lost value to homeowners
across the united states
so just those are my thoughts
and uh i think that it is a a
improper president i think the office
knows this i'm not saying anything to
you all that they are not aware of
but i believe the political forces
uh driving today's events um are just
that
it's uh political politically driven uh
notwithstanding uh the statements
by uh my colleague at the da's office uh
in court today 1.7 million dollars i
know he's not your client
but that's a lot of money what would mr
trump have to say about that
the the allegations in the indictment
are just that they are allegations they
have to be proven
this is these kinds of cases typically
are resolved in the civil context
why because the law on compensation on
fringe benefits
is murky uh difficult it's complex
so he's already distorting this is not
all about fringe benefits that was
something that was expected
it's not only about fringe benefits be
vigorously contested
by people who are experts in the field
and know this law very very well
about his personal faith as a result of
this as they say this could just be the
beginning
of a more lengthy and more thorough
prosecution
the district attorney can say and
announce whatever they would like to say
and announce
we have no concerns going forward
that's all i can say on that matter
the the indictment alleges that that
amount of money
uh was from 2005. i won't even say it
that amount but again the question
is what is it about it's about
apartments is something a corporate
apartment is something uh uh uh properly
uh an expense of the company and these
are complex questions
never charged in a criminal case and
they shouldn't have been here quite
be willing to frankly
all civil cases um
i've been a lawyer a long time my
wonderful colleagues bettina shine says
the necklace been lawyers a long time
all several cases people get into a room
they talk about it
uh often they resolve things um
what can i say your your your own human
experience tell us pretty
an admission of gross we are
we're way before any kind of uh
all i can tell you is all of our common
experience would tell you
that uh civil cases people usually get
in a room
they figure out what the issues are and
and they resolve them that's what
happens organization is affected by this
it's going to be very damaging to the
organization itself
we we are uh very companies very very
optimistic uh
that uh and and we're certainly hopeful
that there will not be
um uh uh significant effects i do remind
you all
that there are large financial
institutions in this
uh in new york city uh very well-known
financial institutions
that were the subject of criminal
prosecutions and that are regulated
entities we're talking banks
we're talking large financial
institutions um
uh and they've all by the way why isn't
the prosecution visiting the border
that's a very funny comment in twitch
chat really well done
is that what is the company
the company is about 3500
employees worldwide many f many of those
are in the united states at these
properties
and hotels and golf clubs and i've been
i visited some of those
and the the people that are employed
are waiters and they're bellmen and
they're busboys
and they clean what was the question
they fixed the meals
and they they are maintenance people and
they take care of the grounds
and they are people from all walks of
life of
every country on the planet um and they
are good
hard working people and so those are the
people
that really are behind this company and
you all should know that
based on what's based on what's in dyson
do you think the real target here is
former president trump i would answer
that by saying
that um certainly
uh given the
given the nature and the unprecedented
nature
of these charges that certainly
that's the reason they were brought okay
if the name of the company was something
else i don't think these charges
would have been brought in fact i am
fairly certain
they would not this guy's slippery huh
no no the answer is no and i'm i'm i'm
going to speak to what we are
talking about today i'm i'm finished i
appreciate you all but uh those are
that's uh what i have to uh talk about
uh this afternoon
thank you alan
feuderfest f-u-t-e-r-f-a it's a fraud
thank you
i just have a few comments to make all
right you were listening to uh
don't cut away the attorney representing
the trump organization
uh making the case that the organization
after pleading not guilty believes that
these charges are
politically all right so there is that
oh here we go cnn has it
donald trump that they wanted to hear
that donald trump had done things
criminally
which they did not the witnesses did not
do because they could not do although
carrie dunn in court said this was not a
political prosecution
i think you can all see what has
happened in the press
what you've seen over the last year and
the comments that attorney general
letitia james
has repeatedly made she campaigned
on a promise that she would get donald
trump
she repeatedly said she would use all
areas
of the law to get donald trump and this
is a joint prosecution while she was
attorney general and when while
president trump was in
office she sued him 70
times so basically character
assassination of the prosecutor just
saying it's a personal vendetta it seems
to be the the strategy right now
yeah wow so this is the person who now
with the da's
office have teamed up together to bring
this
unprecedented prosecution
the da's office may say it's not
unprecedented but they cannot
point to any case any case where a
corporation has been prosecuted based on
a
few individuals in the corporation
who allegedly on their personal tax
return
made a mistake or did not uh pick up
fringe benefits benefits
there is no such case that we have been
able to find
and we do not believe that there is any
such case that they have been able to
find
you cannot say like the da's office said
in court
oh we brought the case because they
didn't cooperate with us
that's not how it works you bring the
case on principles of corporation
of a liability and when a corporation
has done
massive wrongdoing that's what the the
da's office is
guidelines for corporate liability said
and they disregarded
those guidelines to bring a case against
the trump
company never happened before we will
win
this case but this case should have
never
been brought it is a political
prosecution
political prosecutions uh where people
are talking any surprise that they're
the victims as usual
it's just these people this business
this family this
they are always the victims of
everything
it's un-american it should not happen
here in new york city
the greatest city in the greatest
democracy
in the world shouldn't does it matter if
new york city's great or not
like in this context that this occurred
thank you i'm not answering any
questions here thank you
okay we have been listening there to the
attorneys for the church all right so
there's that let's see if msnbc picked
up anything else no not right now
um wow wow what a day
sir you're on the cover of time magazine
again that's going to be
that's going to be an issue that's
certainly going to be an issue
i want to try to get caught up on some
of these super chats because so many of
you have things to say as we are
standing by here big thank you to wendy
bennett who just signed up with the
coupon code what
indictment 21 that is the day it is
indictment day
bradley lehman signed up with the code
indictment 21
nick goldstein signing up ruben
sanchez is a new member ali a
has signed up bobby bo sarge
thanks to jaime chavez with the coupon
code indictment 21
steve bragy is a new member and
bert elin has also signed up that is
seven putting us at 53. uh
that code today part of
the celebration of this first series of
indictments against the trump
organization and his employees
alan weisselberg 15 felony counts
15 felony counts you can use that code
at joinpackman.com also i want to say
thanks to colors atk as well as milo
wild
cue it i am stranded stranded
castlerunner all of whom signed up via
twitch today
remember do not leave your bezos bucks
in jeff
bezos's pocket you don't have to support
me
but if you have amazon prime use that
twitch prime
sub for someone otherwise it just stays
in jeff bezos pocket
for his yacht and his yard yachts
support yacht
and the support yachts yacht and then
that
the helicopter pilot yacht and all of
this different stuff okay that's crazy
raccoon ellie says 15 counts at seven
years per count
yeah he'll flip look how far down you
have to scroll on fox to see this oh
let's check that out
foxnews.com let's see
um okay
i'm looking for it pretty big story not
finding it
here it is okay and down here
all right i mean it's not as far down as
i might have expected it's pretty far
down but it's not as far down as i would
have expected
other super chats do you think
weisselberg will end up like epstein
not even going to get involved in that
now that weisselberg knows the charges
how long before he flips oh let's listen
to michael cohen and see what he has to
say
to see you um your reaction to what
you've heard in this indictment
there's nothing that has been said that
i couldn't have scripted out in advance
of the trump organization's council
whether it was
or uh the other attorney obviously what
what else can donald say what else can
alan weisselberg say
it's political it's political he's been
saying this witch-hunt
sort of language since the very first
day that he took office
no one is allowed to investigate donald
unless donald tells you he's allowed
to be investigated and that's the
problem here so look
everybody has to just take a step back
read through the indictment as it's
written instead of skimming through it
in order to find pieces
what you're going to find is that alan
weisselberg
is in substantially greater jeopardy
than he was last night you know allison
um i've said this before and i want to
say to you as well
there's a big difference between when
you're under investigation
and when you're under indictment the
next step for alan weisselberg
and possibly his children is prison and
we already saw the numbers as by yours
by your group um before of seven years
for each of the
15 counts that's 105 years
that the man is looking now nobody
believes that he's going to get 105
years
but even three like i was charged with
it's a long time
and that feeling of the handcuffs and or
shackles or however else that they
paraded him through
that's real and he knows the reality now
a lot greater than he did yesterday and
so michael i mean because you've been
in this very position in terms of being
indicted and
knowing the difference between an
investigation and an indictment what
we've learned
at least from what has leaked out
immediate reports is that alan
weisselberg was not interested in
cooperating up until now
do you think that today something
changes
yeah i mean he would be crazy not to
because right now
his life is on the line he's 74 years
old
he gets three years five years whatever
it is
that's real time when you're in your
golden years he doesn't want to be away
from his wife and his sons
and his grandchildren he wants to be
with his family he wants to go on down
to boynton beach and enjoy
his golden years of his life not hanging
out with a bunch of other
inmates whether it's uh in an otisville
type scenario of course that's federal
um or wherever they're going to send him
it's not a joke at this point in time
and here's the thing um i think it was
um
it was one of the members of your panel
i forget who it was made a statement
which is very true
what you have right now is alan
weisselberg's head on the chopping block
and do you think that donald trump will
protect him
well if alan looks back at what happened
to me
the answer is an emphatic no he's going
to pay the legal bills up until he gets
tired
of paying the legal bills because why am
i paying for everybody's money
why am i paying for everybody's bills
and then he's going to cut him off it's
no different than what he did to me
first they bring you in they hug you
they tell you everything's gonna be fine
and then when things really get hot
that's when donald runs
and the beauty of donald doing that for
him is he's gonna say
well that's why i paid my cfo that's why
i paid the accounting firm
i also wanted to say to you alan
weisselberg is not
the keystone he is not the keystone to
this investigation
michael i want to ask you about
something that i think you have some
information about personally
yes in the indictment there are some
details about the tuition
okay that went for alan weisselberg's i
think grandchildren
so there is a 359 thousand dollar
check to columbia grammar
school that weisselberg's grandchildren
went to
that it looks like were according to
this indictment
signed by donald trump himself
can you can you do you have any
information about that
of course
what is what's the exact question that
you want why is it signed by donald
how many times on end on all of these
shows do i have to say
there is nothing that happened at the
trump organization
that did not go to donald right whether
it was the purchasing of paper clips
or the payment of alan weisselberg's
grandchildren's tuition
every single thing went on donald's
death
dear god
hold on i'm just making straight in lucy
do you hear me can you hear me michael
michael okay hold on okay we're going to
get michael
back for in a second but right now we
want to bring in ellie
ellie tell me everything wow how nuts is
this huh
this is crazy what's happening um
he told me sir i'm being charged with 15
felonies
sir you can't ask that question nigel
says will don jr shut up for a day
no what happened to the tax and
insurance fraud
um let's see what else we've got here
prediction trump will initially distance
himself from weaselberg
says say he doesn't know him i didn't
know he did this blah blah blah
danny thompson coming in with a stream
record 105 dollar
super chat 15 felony counts and seven
years prison for each
deserves a very strong super chat for
sure
we are going to discover that the
oranges of this investigation
are definitely bananas have a great long
weekend
and thanks for all that you do we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers
mark says did they give him his tie and
belt back i believe they did
kelsey says trump has new social media
platform called
getter okay let's get back to michael
cohen long-time personal attorney so
michael i mean basically
what i'm alluding to with this is that i
know that you have sat
many times with prosecutors and given
them you know what you know
now and so have you been able to point
them to any specific
fraudulent transaction that
you can tie to donald trump that you
think is now connected here
uh-oh right so let me once again say
that i won't discuss
my conversations with the district
attorney out of respect for the
investigation
all i can say is yes uh in the firm
there are a multitude of
documents that are in the possession of
prosecutors that tied donald trump to
everything because everything went
through donald i don't know how many
more times i could possibly say the same
thing
you know every single thing whether it
was the acquisition of paper clips
light bulbs your furniture mattresses
you name it
mattresses allen weisselberg's kids
payments rents
everything would have a donald signature
on it or his initial
and that included and there are other
people at the trump organization
who additionally received the same sort
of perk benefits
that alan weissel big that allen
weisselberg did
trump had he definitely didn't want
anybody getting those pillow tops that
was it just the normal mattress was his
limit
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers their taxes
and why is it that it was done and how
is it that it was done
and booked by the trump organization now
one of the things before i lost you in
terms of sound that i was saying
what donald will do since he doesn't
have emails
is he's gonna claim that this is
everybody else's fault
that's part of the donald strategy
that's his playbook
it's not me it's michael cohen it's not
me it's alan weiselberg
it's not me it's matthew calamari but
then he's gonna say
it's the accounting firm so do you think
that there's
not going to be other people that are
going to step up to the plate
by the way the fact that there's a guy
named calamari who's involved here
i don't know why but that just cracks me
up i i don't even know why it's so funny
that's what's interesting is that though
everything you've said
rings true in the past for everything
that has come up whatever allegations
there have been
somehow donald trump it was a squid pro
quo
nicely done very very nicely done he
didn't and so why do you think this time
is going to be any different
well you know the expression right the
cat has nine lives
i think his nine lives have expired
because the documentary evidence that
are
that's in the hands of the prosecutors
is so significant and it's so spot-on
that there's no way anybody's getting
out of it and again
neither alan weisselberger calamari or
anybody are the keystone here because
the documents speak for themselves
and there are more than enough people
that are carlos spaghetti actually has
really the
treasure trove of documents included
michael i haven't okay i have another
question for you
because you've lived through this what
is donald trump saying
to alan weisselberg right now what what
message is he sending
to him and if they are still speaking i
mean i know that
you were still speaking to him and in
contact until the point where your
apartment and office were raided and
then you would get messages
through his lawyers so what sorts of
messages are coming into alan
weisselberg now
alan congr listen i know what you're
going through
this is terrible it's part of the witch
hunt you know it i know it
stay the course stay strong i have your
back
you know don't worry about the finances
we're going to take care of all of it
we're going to take care of your
attorneys
do not worry right this is all nonsense
it's all
the politicization of you know of the
trump organization and me
they've been fighting for years you know
that we've been through much bigger wars
than this
just stay strong with me and i promise
you i have your back
fraud that sounds pretty persuasive it
sure does but guess what
it's not true because nothing that
donald trump says is true
and alan will be the fall guy just as i
was the fall guy
and listening to these attorneys say
this has never happened it's
unprecedented
it's not true i went to prison in part
for hush money payments
i went because of a campaign finance
violation right
so if you really think that just because
it's alan weisselberg and donald trump
once again saying something
that that's going to become the reality
he could say it all he wants it's not
the reality
michael i'm just still reading through
this indictment uh but
one thing that i want to ask you about
is the indictment alleges that the trump
organization
destroyed business records in september
of 2016.
um do you know what that's in reference
to
um i again this is all part of the da's
prosecution of both the trump
organization weisselberg and others so i
don't want to get into it
but obviously they're not going to make
a
statement like that unless that they
have the information
in order to back it up remember most
most of the stuff that was documents uh
with the
trump organization come in only two
forms it's either electronic
or it's on paper that's just the way
that the way that the company ran
and so if there's um information that's
missing from the hard drive
rest assured quantico knows how to bring
that information back we've seen that
before
and as it relates to paper that's only
one side if
i'm sending you an email okay if i get
rid of it
that doesn't mean that yours is gone so
they will figure out how to get
or if not they already have it the
information that they're looking for
or they're going to have it as a
corroborating witness
michael as you probably heard ellie
honig just outlined from the
indictment there were other people
mentioned other employees
that it sounded like it goes beyond alan
weisselberg
you think this is bigger than alan why
isn't this the best
is next to be indicted well i think that
matthew calamari is on the chopping
block as well he received the same type
of perks
the co the uh same kind of perks and
benefits that alan
shelly shellfish also may be doing hard
time if you know what i mean
believe that there are other members of
the trump organization
including the children uh who are next
to come up onto these indictments
you don't mean allen weisselberg's
children you mean donald trump's you
mean eric
and don jr and ivanka correct
and what do you think they would be
indicted for well again their
participation in different aspects
um of the company and how they ended up
booking things for tax purposes
matthew calamari took and received uh
and
again i don't want people to think that
this case
is about alan weisselberg in an
apartment and a free
car and so on it is substantially larger
in scope than just that aspect that is
but
the tip that's the tip of the iceberg
and there's
so much more that's going to be coming
so
you know again to take this indictment i
think ellie honig said it best um before
which is that there are different ways
that different prosecutors
run their cases in this specific case
they're doing it this way
they could have done a sweeping
indictment against 10 12 15 people
if they really wanted but they're not
they're doing it in a methodical way and
despite the fact that as a society now
we like our information immediate and we
want things to be done on the spot
that's not realistic in this specific
case because you are going after them
i mean but if this is the tip of the
iceberg what's the iceberg what more
is about to drop well the ultimate which
is what they're
really looking to do the the target of
this investigation
is not alan weisselberg of course it's
the ceo
of the trump organization donald trump
himself
michael cohen we really appreciate you
sharing your
particular unique insights into the
trump organization
as well as all this investigation with
us great to talk to you
thanks alison what a crazy situation huh
i don't care what they name it name it
peaches
yeah so there is michael cohen always
saying go away
so you may want to smarten up and think
about providing the information
that they already have in corroborating
it if not
you know we'll i'm sure we'll talk about
it in 20 years from now
we'll see if he takes your advice
michael cohen thank you very much
be well allison all right so there is
michael cohen
dropping a few bombs there uh let's see
what
msnbc is reporting uh that's the uh
district attorney's office
response on the record in court uh we'll
continue to comb through
a little bit more of this speech and
obviously continue to share with you but
that's what he said
uh to the judge i do want to read one
other section sorry amen
he said finally address what this case
is not about it's not about politics
dunn says this investigation which is
ongoing has been thorough
careful and proper and has been limited
to subject matters
so i think we we don't necessarily need
to be hearing that but uh what a day huh
what
what an incredible day um
a few people people having a good time
with matthew calamari
ferret queen says sam sushi has been
raided the fbi said something seemed
fishy
david says how about matthew calamari's
uncle tony marinara
ali says calamari forced trump into a
squid
pro quo charles says calamari is just
the tip of the iceberg wait until they
indict
marty meatballs and don't forget about
former trump bodyguard
gabe a ghoul um
okay yeah so a lot really happening
there
tony marinara you should see that's
that's a guy
uh with some spice on his shoulder i
want to say thank you to natasha
estes who just signed up with the coupon
code
indictment 21. it is indictment day if
you've been saying
you know what sir uh i will sign up for
a membership
when somebody gets indicted in the trump
organization
that day is today and you can sign up on
my website with the code indictment 21
jamie mulvihill has also done that
new members 59 and 60 today
also a big thank you to artistic
simplicity via twitch
nasty questions lie hair
it's the mac attack co-lion
moss parkman i don't know what that
means um
real time fan rose from the ashes
sparrows barkley kerr
norfolk in luck shark flops
the mike lennon all signing up really
strongly via
via super chat putting us i'm sorry via
twitch prime
putting us at 69 for the day
and we are very close to running out of
those indictment 21
super chats by the uh memberships
the website has almost been completely
exhausted
so that is uh there's limited time left
any news about
paul mango well yeah i mean um
uh that that actually reminds me
um diamond and silk
uh they had a really really strong uh
they they denounced mango
prices i guess it was um
oh i think this is my own club
yeah this is my that's funny this is my
own clip mangoes my bag of mangoes
up under trump cost me eight dollars i
love mangoes too nine
cents okay now that we are up under our
body's regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't mangoes like
three bucks each
that's it i want what eight or 11 bucks
that sounds good
then the american people belong and
highway robbery is what you're doing
who knew mango could get people so
worked up
bring my mangoes back down that's right
right about that the wisconsin crowd not
identifying with the mango material
unfortunately that's kind of funny
actually i raised the price
of fruit don't you want me to be healthy
don't you
yeah okay all right very good very very
good
no further comment on that from me um
but the mango material
playing really well there i wonder what
the fox news sycophants will say tonight
i think we know i think we know
um i think we we know exactly what to
expect
from those folks okay
um yeah
so that's basically what's going now are
we curious like how newsmax might be
covering this
i i'm like a little bit curious let's
just see
newsmax like by the way newsmax
has been slamming us with copyright
claims
i just oh so nothing's going on yeah
manipulation
through a process called gain of
function risk just for even showing this
we'll probably get hit with a copyright
strike i'll do a story on that next week
pathogen uh i think that chances are
that they were working on it and it was
funded by the military uh
very i'm very confident that i assessed
that the most likely origin
was an accidental infection of
laboratory personnel
from the wuhan institute of virology
what's that buzzing by the way
transmission to the local population and
subsequent spread to hundreds of
millions of people
around the world the noise
why is it significant and worthwhile
that we figure
this out i think if we don't
look into this if we're we're turning a
blind eye towards this
so 15 felonies over 15 years
against trump cfo and this is what
newsmax is currently covering make of
that
sort of what you will i guess thanks to
zilli
doe for the twitch prime sub appreciate
that you're number 70 today very very
much appreciate it
also want to say thank you to dale
bowers with the coupon code
indictment21 and gregory hardy signing
up with the code
indictment 21. all right guys so that's
the news
of really strong indictment trump
organization indicted on
10 counts trump's uh cfo
indicted on 15 counts so i will
more than likely stream the trump rally
on
saturday it does conflict with argentina
versus ecuador
uh in copa america but i i will see
we'll see if we can work that out if
trump doesn't start late i could at
least do like the first
hour so that's my plan i will see
everybody
saturday um appreciate the super chats
appreciate the subscriptions i really
appreciate all of it and we will
review the brand new song
from office akimov on the way out
moment of the sexual experience will ask
the young lady who's your
daddy this should be remixed if officer
akimov
is watching this could be the next remix
masterpiece dude because just wait till
you see what happens here oh officer
officer
akimov is here uh that's beautiful
who's your dad i'm joined today by
pastor james david manning
oh i'm a christian
[Music]
i'm joined today by pastor james david
[Music]
manning
is the most successful pimp on planet
earth
to reverence the word of god to trust it
to preach it
to teach it loads and
loads of money and tons and tons of
lives
loads and loads of money and tons and
tons of lives
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus
what happened in prison that brought you
to jesus china
china george bush and george bush jr
have been penetrated
by at least 100 men in their anus a
hundred thousand
two hundred thousand strong i didn't do
it
on my knees
i didn't do it but i was tempted
[Music]
loads and loads of money and
tons and tons of
[Music]
they say something to you about
marketing
[Music]
starbucks has done the exact same thing
that coca-cola has done
except they've done it we've seen them
that certainly
seems to be a story that has been missed
[Music]
um
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and tv program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman
[Music]
david pacman he is
can you remind the audience when you
talk about
being a beta male and being an alpha
male what are we talking about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1
they think and act like a woman they are
emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but
whoa whoa jesse will we we gotta that's
a lot
that's raw abortion they think and act
just like a woman obeying a male doctor
but another baby doesn't because he's a
logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david
[Music]
david pacman he is
[Music]
david patman he is
[Music]
[Music]
you're not here to communicate i really
appreciate you coming on i'm going to
let you go it's a waste of time to talk
to you
we're not communicating you're actually
like because you're asking bizarre
questions you're actually like
and you're wasting my time i appreciate
that
[Music]
[Applause]
all men who are progressive
[Music]
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pacman show he's got a lot of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to
add his name at the end of the subject
[Music]
he'll hit you with some facts
empirical at that
and once or twice a week he'll mention
about
his gardens pretty good garden now but
it's not for everyone
you should also know
that there is a bonus show
producer pat will give his take which is
a pretty
decent perspective pat knows what he's
talking about
if you're thinking about joining the
david
pacman show he's got lots of
content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add